[Music]
so big night for you yes best new artist
nominee wildest dream you think you'd be
here
yeah never never thought it would be
possible like I would like daydream
about winning a Grammy one day or even
like being here so the fact that I am
here is like really weird I haven't I
haven't processing it it's very I feel
like it's really weird you're you you're
so young but you're like an old soul
like I'm serious because you have a
point of view already you have a message
already and you're determined to like
change the conversation for women
already thank you so much I think it's
important to do that you know I feel
like it would be wasting my platform if
I just stayed silent about everything or
didn't use my music and anyway you know
so I'm trying trying my best you have a
really powerful of performance yes tell
me what we can expect from it um well I
don't want to get too much away
especially because it's not my perform
at this logic so I'm just accompanying
him but I think it's gonna be really
powerful he he always does really
powerful things that I mean the song
kind of speaks for itself so it'll be
really nice Khalid was telling me too
that you know he hopes that just your
all's generation really gets what
they're saying you're not alone
hmm you're just not it's true it's true
like no matter where you're from no
matter who you are we all deal with
struggles I've dealt with my own - and
it's okay to sometimes feel like you
know you're down and you're not good
enough but as long as you don't believe
it and as long as eventually you realize
that you are and if me as an artist can
help anybody realize that and help them
realize that it does actually get better
than they're saying
yeah okay weren't you saying that you
are going to perform scars stripped down
and just no-makeup nofilter why is it
important for you to do that um I think
I think the message sometimes gets
misconstrued about that because I I
don't want it to seem like I'm saying
like make up is bad or this is bad
because that's not the case I wear I'm
wearing makeup right now I just think it
was important if I'm making a song and
singing a song and performing a song
about being yourself and about loving
every part of who you are regardless I
think it's important to be exactly
myself and stripped down and say if I'm
comfortable doing this and I've dealt
with struggles about how I look - so it
was more of even a thing for me to say
like wow I'm here at this amazing event
and that I've always dreamed of but I
can still do it being me besides your
performance you and logic and and clean
who are you excited to see me oh my gosh
so many people that I've never seen
before
I think it's Rihanna performing I think
she's doing wild yeah Bryson tiller and
dj khaled that's gonna be amazing yeah
so many different people scissor of
course I saw her in rehearsal I was like
freaking out yeah because she's
incredible I love her
[Music]